côté en tout cas grand merci pour lui il
nous a fait vivre pour une toute petite
boîte comme la nôtre une aventure
extraordinaire a démarré à cannes passer
par les oscars
et puis finit ici quoi on consomme au
dos c'est en plus d'être un grand
artiste c'est aussi un homme extrêmement
intègre et droit ce qui est quand même
relativement rares et j'ai pas mal de
remerciement à faire j'espère je vais
pas me prendre la musique pour me couper
je voudrais d'abord remercier l'équipe
du joker ce parce qu'ils vont quand même
beaucoup trimé donc terme martin et
notre directrice générale donc c'est une
femme elle est en jeunes là-bas au fond
elle s'appelle violaines je voudrais
remercier l'équipe des bookmakers zh qui
a programmé le film cet été sans prendre
de vacances donc dans plus de 800 salles
sophie noémie et elisa je voudrais
également remercier mon ami bruno barde
qui nous a accompagné avec l'équipe du
public système cinéma depuis plus de 20
ans et puis j'ai trois dédicace à faire
en fait une qui devrait pas vous plaire
mais je vais en profiter quand même là
excusez moi j'ai un message à faire
passer à ces voix le message il est prêt
il se peut pas fermer dédicaces si tu
peux mais on fait d'abord un ex agent
non mais reste là on met le message a
pas de hordes tout ce que tu veux
ok inquiète sa la famille
[Musique]
m
après l'amour
[Musique]
ils ont dit qu'ils allaient me suis
beaucoup plus onéreux
alors ce petit clip a été tourné par
notre ami jesus castro bon je ne sortais
d'un d'une entrevue avec le président
sud-coréen et avec son équipe sont tout
de suite revenue à des vraies valeurs
enfin celle qu'on aime en tout cas là
donc je vais faire quand même les
dédicaces donc comme je considère qu'il
ya une toute petite partie de ce césar
qui nous revient elle est toute petite
mais quand même je vous entends que
marcy je voudrais dédier ce césar tous
les marseillais ou supporters de l'om
l'a ensuite toujours pour la petite
partie le dédié aux 1 million 800 mille
personnes qui ont vu le film en salles
en version originale sous titrée c'est
bien on est fier de vous et par contre
là c'est le césar tout entier de la part
de bong joon ho et accessoirement la
mienne on la dédie à tous les parasites
du monde entier parce qu'une société
uniquement construite sur la course aux
profits la matraque c'est quand même pas
terrible et donc on espère qu'il y aura
mieux pour les générations qui arrivent
merci pour bong joon ho
[Applaudissements]